[Music]
impeccable timing captain i was about to
watch the latest episode in halcyon
helen's thrilling cereal adventure
welcome back captain
how can i be of assistance
certainly captain i was hoping you would
ask
[Music]
it was the law forsaken parasites
i had become obsessed
my quest to stop them
to avenge my partner philip
and my ex-partner bernice
and lieutenant jorgen
and those two informants
had brought me to rizzo's distillery
[Music]
but it wasn't just the triple distilled
deliciousness of rizzo spectrum brand
vodka that i found there
[Music]
it was death
i made sure the brain eaters paid the
price
[Music]
but at what cost to me
it's you
[Music]
this is the halcyon news network with
breaking news halcyon helen has been
murdered administrator ludovico of
rizzo's refused to answer the big
question on everyone's mind who will
spectrum vodka's next spokesperson be
claiming that a special investigation
must be concluded first
captain we have a communication coming
in from one administrator ludovico
get off the transmission cedric we
agreed to let me do the negotiating
lobby with you friend i am administrator
ludovico of the famed eridano's
atmospheric complex
but there's no need to stand on
formality you may address me as mister
halcyon helen
is dead
murdered
her death is the tragedy of our lifetime
as the face of our new product line her
murder is a stain on the rizzo's brand
she was scheduled to unveil our newest
product spectrum brown before this
tragic event
but we cannot move forward with our
unveiling until we apprehend the killer
[Music]
all right ludovico that's enough you
don't know what you're doing let me
handle this
captain hawthorne i've been looking
forward to meeting agitant akande's
favorite gun
cedric kin cannon sublight underground
i'm so glad we're hiring a third party
investigator no one wants to see a troop
of udl guards stomping all over my hotel
least of all me
the murder of halcyon helen is
a heinous assault on this colony
i look forward to watching you find the
miscreant responsible and drag them out
of the shadows
[Music]
you're a compassionate person captain
and you're right halcyon helen was a
talented woman
she had a gift for transforming her art
into wealth
she would not believe the money she made
us on dissident busters for law's sake
cedric could you show a little
discretion and not bring up your
contraband operations in front of an
outsider
please lou sublight underground is built
on discretion i'm establishing rapport
with our new contractor let's not give
her the impression that you can't be
trusted
do you really want to do this right now
cedric you want to antagonize me while
i'm negotiating a contract because i
promise you i'll win
first sensible thing i've heard all day
oh uh my apologies mr ludovico that was
unprofessional of me
captain i'm constable maria keane hiring
a third-party investigator was my idea
i've been studying your dossier
you are adjutant akande's most reliable
freelancer if the second most powerful
person in halcyon can depend on you
then i'd like to think we can depend on
you as far as i'm concerned you're the
ideal inspector for this case
i'm pleased to hear that the future of
our complex may depend on your success
i'll leave you in the constable's care
mr can cannon and i must have
a word
fine
but rizzo's is paying for that hotel
room i can't tell you how grateful i am
for your help and even though they may
not show their gratitude i know
administrator ludovico and mr kincannon
appreciate your involvement
mr kincannon could lose his spaceport if
board authorities took over the
investigation and if rizzos is forced to
cancel its unveiling
we might never recover
transmission terminated
captain we are now cleared to land at
the eredano's atmospheric complex
aerodynamos is a hydrogen helium gas
giant distinguished by a well-defined
ring system
the aerodynos atmospheric complex is a
system of land masses propelled through
a thin layer of the upper atmosphere
where humans are potentially capable of
surviving
quick touchdown on the atmospheric
complex in aerodynamics
you know we don't have to catch helen's
pillar right in a second
maybe we ought to take in the sights
hello hello hello there hope your
atmospheric entry wasn't too troublesome
as a guest of honor you deserve the best
in comfort
sublight salvage and shipping
underground or slug as we like to call
ourselves is delighted to welcome you to
eridanos
i'm the grand colonial head bellhop i'm
here to grab your bags and direct you
the inspector to the grand ballroom
which was the scene of the crime
i can try i was the one who found
helen's body in the grand ballroom
corpse wasn't in the best shape
aside from that i don't know a whole lot
helen was supposed to host the unveiling
for rizzo's newest product spectrum
brown
until you catch the killer the unveiling
has been indefinitely postponed
helen's death has been a shock for many
a lot of people are inconsolable
hell even black hole birdie helen's bow
has wandered off
some folks think he had something to do
with the murder but
yeah i don't believe it
hey
black hole birdie may be a savage brood
on the field of honor but he's no killer
emergency stain and accident
disappearing goop capsules are currently
low on capacity would you like to order
a new 5 000 caps carton of goop for this
unit folks get heated when it comes to
cereals and their actors i suppose
not particularly but i think some folks
were jealous of her success or otherwise
viewed her as a threat
reckon how she came about her fame
didn't help
actually helen didn't do anything like
that she was just so stellar in her
roles and the public liked her so much
that she got a following all on her own
she ended up about as famous and
high-runged as your average vp which
rubbed a lot of byzantines the wrong way
actors ain't supposed to get
preferential treatment
let's see here
oh i already spoke briefly about the
spectrum unveiling or lack thereof
it's still an awful shame a lot of folks
looking forward to that
[Music]
you bet it was rizzo's rented at the
ballroom in the hotel just for the
launch event
reckoned it was going to be a real swell
affair rizzo zane unveiled the product
since the debut of spectrum ultraviolet
invisible to the naked eye and as it
happened prone to causing massive
internal bleeding
anyway i think i've held you up long
enough once you're ready head down to
the lobby the ballroom is just behind
the elevators
meanwhile i'll grab your bags
[Music]
uh you're making fun right
your luggage
belongings kits
wherever you keep what you ain't wearing
you're still giving me a pretty blank
look
suppose it's
none of my business but do you just wear
the same set of clothes all the time
see you say that but i still ain't
seeing no bags
know what never mind it's not my
business
anyhow i'll look for you in the grand
ballroom later
hope you can unravel this mystery
inspector
[Music]
greetings inspector
no need to check in here your paperwork
has all been processed
[Music]
rizzo's purpleberry punch you want a
punch we've got your punch right here
so famous as halcyon helen could meet a
fate like this
report the immediate vicinity is
10 bits this is all just some sort of
public what
oh thank the law inspector you don't
know how relieved i am to see you
constable maria keane
it's good to meet you in person
inspector
dr goodnight ecstatic to make your
various acquaintances and so on are we
finished with the pleasantries there's
something i'm excited to show you
an extraordinary contraption you'll love
it our coroner has developed a device
which may prove useful in your
investigation
our office has instructed her to hand it
over to you
our office has instructed you to hand it
over to you oh please you make it sound
as if i'm turning over stolen goods
behold
my discrepancy amplifier
hold it in your hands
feel the way it hums with ontological
potential
i'm so glad you asked allow me to
explain the discrepancy amplifier uses a
deterministic model of our universe to
detect the discrepancy between what
should be and what actually is
then it renders any discrepancies
visible by using the power of
magnification
[Music]
it's
yes
it's a magnifying glass but an
extraordinarily powerful one it looks
through the glass of reality itself i'm
contractually prohibited from endorsing
off-brand technology but
i'll bend that rule just this once
you'll want to peer into the amplifier
and examine the crime scene
this unit has detected a discrepancy
related to halcyon helen unscheduled
expiration of begin amplification
please do not daunt the discrepancy
amplifier
oh you'll love this amplifier tell the
inspector about your features please do
not interrupt the discrepancy amplifier
the discrepancy amplifier is programmed
to take instruction from its registered
or designated inspector how curious
i must have set its impertinence levels
to flagrant this unit's features include
an automated personality simulator this
unit has been programmed to stimulate
joy and satisfaction in assisting you
this is a bottle of unreleased rizzo's
product helen appears to have attempted
to use it to spell something as she
expired but all she managed was a sticky
bee
this hypothesis is plausible but
requires additional information
i was wondering about that before we
arrived i heard something on the aether
waves about black hole birdie taken up
at the grand colonial correct bertie
blackhole holcomb is a registered guest
at the grand colonial hotel
accessing guest database b the grand
colonial hotel is proud to serve the
following vips bertie come on black hole
burbidge 3001.
evidence has been recorded for later
reference now generating pre-approved
compliment splendid work inspector
this footprint stands out from the
normally spotless floor of the grand
ballroom typically the ballroom is
cleaned twice daily which means this
must have been made by either helen or
her assailant or a silence
footprint is a teller made 8.75
suggesting that its owner was very
particular about their shoe size it is
also the exact size that halcyon helen
typically prefers there are traces of
dirt throughout the footprint
excellent observation inspector the
following compounds have been detected
purpleberry residue nitrogen-rich
fertilizer common grass grass fertilizer
and purple berries can all be found in
the purple berry orchard located not far
from the grand colonial
this deduction appears
sound
good work inspector
i had a feeling we'd make some progress
once we brought you onto the case you'll
need administrator ludovico to grant you
access to the orchards contact him
through the secure access terminal in
your penthouse suite check in with the
concierge your room should be ready by
now
if it isn't i may have to go shake
someone by the caller
you got a second
[Music]
so
i knew i should have gotten her
autograph when i had the chance this
body has not been disposed of in a
board-approved waste receptacle printing
citation ticket 9554-pkf
i'm sorry ma'am but while the hotel is
an active crime scene i regret to inform
you that all new bookings room upgrades
room downgrades and in-room massages are
suspe
oh you're the special inspector mr
kincannon warned me you'd be checking in
soon
ah yes we are most pleased to offer you
our grandest of grand accommodations
inspector the penthouse suite on our
topmost floor is now available for you
the last guest left her belongings
behind when she vacated unexpectedly so
we needed a little time to tidy the
suite up for you
simply call the elevator in the lobby
and our highly skilled operator will
deliver you to your private floor with
efficiency and cheer
my apologies inspector but that would be
a severe violation of guest privacy we
here at the grand colonial firmly
believe that
all right my supervisor just walked out
of your shot some folks just don't
understand the importance of gossip
about whom and what would you wish to
know
you know out of everyone here i probably
knew the least about helen
i'm not much of an ather wave watcher
myself
[Music]
and helen always had a crowd of admirers
chasing her you see
so she rarely stopped to chat friendly
enough surely but always seemed
untouchable
emphasis unseemed
everyone wanted to be around helen she
could usually be seen alongside birdie
or wool rich for obvious reasons
ah birdie
is he bigger than he is dumb or dumber
than he is big
i have a bet with a friend not sure
we'll ever get it to pay out bertie used
to be helen's bow though he isn't
anymore and not just because she's dead
if i had a million bits i'd spend
everyone just to learn what caused their
split
if looks could kill
he'd have put her in the ground 10 times
over
man's clearly jealous of her success
compared to his
see i'd bet we're the only two people
thinking about him in all of aeredanos
and i only am because you mentioned his
name
if you leave wooly cow milk out it turns
to curds
leave the curds out they begin to get
stale then rot
wool ridge is on his way to the trash
bin and everyone knows it either he's in
denial or he knew helen would be
checking out soon judging by his
increasing demands for a room upgrade
that's a shame inspector
what if i wanted to know a little about
you
a woman of mystery are you consider me
intrigued
inspector i understand you've visited
the scene of the crime
halcyon helen was an important cultural
icon she will be sorely missed
halcyon helen was more than a character
she was a brand her death will now be
associated with rizzo's spectrum brown
you understand why that worries me
stop please warn me before you provide
me with unsolicited ideas there are
waivers you need to sign
back to the matter at hand tell me about
your investigation
[Music]
your discretion is appreciated i admit
i'm beginning to feel more confident in
this arrangement here i'm granting you
access through the gates to the orchards
you're officially authorized to see this
investigation through to the end
there is one caveat cedric's being
rather intransigent about letting you
into the spaceport
possibly he's trying to hide something
possibly he wants to annoy me
possibly
both
i agree with the sentiment behind your
snide remark unfortunately the perez
spaceport is cedric's purview not mine
you have a lead to chase law speed
inspector
hi there inspector
i
[Music]
the imprint left inside this suitcase
matches the silhouette of halcyon
helen's iconic handgun the needler the
weapon was recently removed
so
[Music]
helen
where did we go wrong
oh i'm so sorry
that didn't mean for
[Laughter]
helen
i love you
oh so sorry but you're not actually
authorized to visit that floor
what authorized floor can i bring you to
to the lobby we
[Music]
i love you
i love you so much
hey you got a minute
you know they're gonna make a serial
about our adventures one day
i've been trying to think of a good
title for this episode
i like the sound of
the skip job
no no wait i got it
hope in dark times
get it pope
like the ship
that's what folks in the business call
wordplay
hey nice
you can totally pull off the tough as
nail's hard-ass boss with no sense of
humor
and everybody thinks you're serious and
professional all the time
except at the end when you sacrifice
your life for the good of the team
proving you cared all along
wait no
don't do that
[Music]
right i'm overdoing it again got it
sorry boss
i'm just excited you know
stealing the hope from the board
skipping it across the whole damn system
this is gonna be great i can't wait
[Music]
come on bob i'm sure you've got plans to
make as for me
i gotta keep practicing my signature
dropkick
the hope might have cameras
[Music]
warning the liquid in this pool is
currently toxic swimming is not advised
for elderly customers
and laps rats
a sudden death knockout court
it's pretty much just toss ball for
folks who don't want to get their hands
dirty
and when i can't get ahold of anyone
[Music]
oh
right
[Music]
returning
timeline discrepancy detected nearby
our line is perfectly detected nearby
[Music]
expiration
evidence strongly suggests a conflict
with marauders
customer would you like to steam clean
this blood-stained uniform say yes
within 10 seconds to confirm
timeline discrepancy detected nearby
this card also expired prematurely
following a violent encounter with
marauders
[Music]
never knew purple berries grew in trees
guess you're wearing something new
discrepancy detected nearby
[Music]
these footprints match the shoes
previously analyzed in the grand
ballroom there is a 110 percent chance
with a 10 margin of error and they were
left by ruth bellamy the actress known
as halcyon helen
[Music]
high traffic areas are the most
susceptible to mud stains and ground in
soil buildup deploying tarmac shampoo
[Music]
wow
you sound
[Music]
inspector you've discovered more
footprints belonging to the deceased
actress known as
timeline discrepancy detected
congratulations inspector you've
discovered more close friends
timeline congratulations
oh
[Music]
i just wanna be your
to friend efforts
job classification
flawlessly finished
hey
oh wait wait i'm supposed to say the
slogan
okay you can do this anna
um here goes
it doesn't matter if you're you or me
we're all part of the rizzo's family
how was that
it was um
it was really
ouch well your candors are pushy i'm
sure you've guessed it but i'm not the
best at remembering slogans and when i
can't remember them i tend to just make
them up but i guess that's why i'm just
an intern and not a full-timer at least
not yet
oh yes i thought i saw someone who
looked self-important enough to be her
by the conservatory some time ago
not to speak ill of the dead i simply
never liked the way she stole the
limelight from the true star
burbitch 3001
who
i certainly am
that aerodynamic chassis how the light
glints off his rotund head
the way he enunciates
cry havoc and let loose the canaans of
war
excuse me
i got a little lightheaded there
nobody does shakespeare like burbage
what were we talking about
i suppose though
i also
[Music]
timeline discrepancy detected nearby
congratulations inspector you've
discovered more footprints
timeline discrepancy detected nearby
[Music]
reality
can we
do that again
uh
[Music]
oh
weapons
[Music]
oh
resistance
[Music]
how it's done
oh
[Music]
gotta get past that armor
[__] careful
[Music]
i was just getting started
nearby
bits of wicker detected embedded within
the chunks of dark matter wickers
the only members of a toss ball team
strong enough to crack a stick into are
the dedicated hackers like michael
bertie whatever miss ruth bellamy must
have relayed to the toss paul hacker
during their painting together
instigated a furious increase in his
usual strength threshold by 52
maximum carnage cleanup
[Music]
hmm
refilling water tanks with internal
condensers
[Music]
happens
you've never laid down on the job
[Music]
i don't know if you're keeping count but
i'm pretty sure every lab in this colony
has got some horrible experiment going
on
hello
i can hear you out there
if you still possess the majority of
your mental capacities please locate the
test room through the lobby and to the
left you'll see me through the glass
how and the eighth or did you get in
here you're not a rizzo's authorized
avoid it all
what does it even matter now
what do you want
speak up and quickly if you will
you do know that halcyon helen is a
fictional character portrayed by the
late actress ruth bellamy yes
one can't be too sure with so many
simpletons around in the day today
regardless i am not at liberty to
divulge such information with
non-employees or personnel lacking
security clearance level spectrum orange
of course if you were to say
contract your services to me i suppose i
could grant you clearance enough to
answer your murder-related questions ms
inspector
you see i've found myself in a bit of a
pickle some of my lab techs have turned
rather aggressive following a recent
experiment gone awry hence why i've
barricaded myself in the lab
yes
i suppose i should make myself useful
let me think
ah
i know
i can remotely unlock the supply closets
in the lower levels of the lab perhaps
you'll find some useful apparatus or two
in them
[Music]
oh no they're quite unaware of their
actions i'm afraid
we're a research and development branch
of rizzos focused primarily on the
spectrum vodka line but the specific
research that goes on in this facility
is utterly confidential you understand
so you've no qualms about snooping
through my precious research files but
will you understand the data once you've
acquired it
essentially we researched new
innovations for an array of resource
products
my present troubles stem from one we've
just developed the product's potential
for profit is nearly limitless but i'm
afraid explaining the science behind it
would far exceed your capability for
understanding
[Music]
now
was there anything else
excellent you have my gratitude and soon
you'll have my knowledge of miss
bellamy's recent visit as well
now if you'd rather not kill my lab
techs during this cleanup i believe you
can dispense a sedative gas from a
terminal in the utility room all types
of defilement must be
vaporized with extreme prejudice
the door to the lower labs is sealed for
our safety so you'll need to take the
elevator down
i'll unseal the access hallway for you
now
do take care
[Music]
staying identified source arterial blood
spray
dispensing mix of sawdust and ab surgery
that's funny
what could that russian infestation
encroaching
smile
is
who's laughing now
[Music]
i just wanted to make you smile
make
[Music]
unit free call
on my oh boss
please return for consultation at once
and do remember unauthorized access to
confidential videos information is a
capital offense
[Music]
wait
what do you think you are
what was that
boss we gotta move
[Music]
dr blossom was a horrible
but she was gonna
pray with you
somebody wanted to keep her quiet
confirmation of discrepancy confirmed is
[Music]
what do you think happened
affirmative customer there is a total
spillage of 0.0591
[Music]
we gotta hunt this killer down
bossy detective nearby
[Music]
timeline discrepancy detected nearby
body heat readings indicate that the
culprit was just here mere moments
earlier in the timeline
[Music]
attention all personnel
unscheduled volunization cycle is about
to commence
please evacuate the orchards at this
time
[Music]
dirt alert
tether engaged
returning to customers
[Music]
foreign